okay uh yeah that's gonna go right there
i would love to know this person's
entire chart because i like that's the
most shocking thing i've ever read
[Music]
so grab from here right here
okay
oh
my mom values the way i look more than
she values me as a person
it really hurts to
to read this because my mom
at times also reacts the same way and i
know that it's a matter that she
i know it's a means of survival as
opposed to a true reflection of like her
love for me but
the fact that this is so prominent
just really hurts
this is [ __ ] up my grandpa sent me a
four page letter about how it's my fault
my uncle molested me when i was 12 years
old that's [ __ ] up like i said
that's hella [ __ ] up
you're not alone
you're not the only one
your grandpa's horrible
um that's
that's awful it's absolutely not your
fault at all you were just a child
you might love your grandpad stuff but
personally your grandpa
um
wow
i feel the need
to please my parents
even if it means harming myself mentally
i think that's so sad
and as a parent
i hope my daughter didn't leave this
although it does sort of look like cat
um
i would tell them that your parents
would want you to be happy their hopes
for you probably are that you're just
you're happy with who you are and you
shouldn't be
living your life pleasing other people
feeling that you have to do that so
when i miss him i play this playlist he
shared with me
yeah i do that too actually
you probably gotta find some new music
let's see get over it a little bit you
know
i feel extreme
anxiousness around white people i cannot
find the courage to be myself around
even white friends as someone with a
minority background
i think it's understandable people find
people are anxious when they're anxious
for different reasons
all right my own
i didn't think i'd live this long but
i'm happy i stuck it out
i'm happy you're here too
i'm balding as a teen and it's
humiliating
i don't like how i look
like my first thought was same and then
my second thought was just
that's so sad that so many people feel
this way i think this is a feeling
that's most strongly felt by
the individual about themselves and not
by the individual in relation to other
people
like most people are
by far more critical of their own
appearance than anyone else's appearance
i wish that wasn't something that was
such a common experience
i've never been kissed
i mean i've never been kissed either
like i got you like i understand
what you're where you're coming from
yeah
i love that
okay
i fold it
how do i feel
i feel kind of sad yeah
um i don't know because like it's just i
feel like on the outside it looks like i
have like such like a nice life and
stuff
and like i always feel the need to like
be perfect but like i'm not
sometimes i think getting a sugar daddy
would be easier
yeah that's funny um i mean i guess it'd
be easier in some ways but harder than
others right
unless you really like sugar daddy
right
but if you didn't like them and you're
purely monetary then that's
that's basically a normal job
okay there you go
ready at large
i found decides about my brother-in-law
because i enjoy his company more than my
husbands
i made out with my aunt's neighbor's
daughter for a pudding cup
i think that's a pretty high price to
pay
i think that you did well and i would do
that myself you know cheers to you
whoever you are i'm proud of you i
sometimes wonder what it would be like
to sleep with my girlfriend's mother and
i can't stop
that's interesting i feel like that's
like not an uncommon thought for people
there's literally isn't stacy's mom
about sleeping with his girlfriend's mom
i feel like that's not the first person
who had that but
it is unfortunate if you can't stop if
it's like compulsive that's tough you've
got a relatable song at least about if
there's a song about it it's not that
bad that's what i say i feel like it's
okay
i am a stripper and i love it i have two
masters but i prefer to dance than
staying in the office
honestly i'm all here for this energy do
what you love
i mean life's pretty short so
if you like to do that keep doing it and
two masters wow impressive
i'm still getting my undergraduate
degree so kudos to you
i feel like a weight has been lifted off
kind of my shoulders a little bit i
haven't like
i guess told anybody so i'm like looking
forward to hopefully finding advice to
like the secret i put
i was sexually active with all my
friends girlfriends to prove that they
weren't loyal
oh my god
um
i guess i'm hoping that you told your
friends that they weren't loyal just so
that they leave the people you hooked up
with
i'm also thinking you're
whatever your astrology sign is it's
very rogue because i just like why would
you do that
i i don't even that's really all i have
to say
if i had to guess their sign
this is oh my god maybe
maybe a scorpio i would love to know i
would love to know this person's entire
chart because i like that's the most
shocking thing i've ever read
[Laughter]
how do i tell him i want to be with him
that's so cute
you gotta just tell him rip the band-aid
off
me and my boyfriend have been together
for a year and eight months and it was
super rocky at the start and he
literally just ripped the band-aid off
and look at us now because we were
friends first so
it worked out really well
so the secret goes i don't like asking
for help in anything especially math
because i fear that people will think
that i'm a dumb person
i've been told a lot of negative things
because of my slow learning learning
i'm ashamed of not being able to know
math like the rest of the kids
i relate to this one maybe not math
probably a different discipline but i
very much relate and i've worked very
hard to hide the fact that i don't learn
as well as others but
i've also come to embrace the fact that
it doesn't matter and we each have our
own
own spectacular things whether it's
learning or not so
it'll be okay whoever this is
you'll be okay the answer is 42.
i feel more determined to fix what i
wrote down
it's something i think about a lot but
i've never really vocalized it never
really written it down
um
but it's something i definitely battle
and i hide from
so now that it's written down and now
that someone else will see it hopefully
i feel more determined to fix it and
think about it
but
yeah yeah life is finite
when i was 12 i survived a terrorist
attack in syria i don't talk about it
i've never hugged anybody in 21 years of
my life
i just recently bought my wedding dress
my boyfriend and i aren't even engaged
yet
i think i want to end my relationship of
5 years but i'm afraid to be single i
know one of my best friends as babies
isn't his but i can't bring myself to
break his heart i worry that after my
time at university i am less interesting
engaged and happy than i was before
oh
um it says i was going to tell my
grandma
that i appreciate her in person for
helping my parents immigrate but she
passed before i got the courage to
um
wow that's actually really sad i
um
i don't really know what to say but like
i think it's good that you at least got
the courage to like think about it and
um like she's in a better place now so
definitely think about that oh yeah and
one thing i forgot to say is like i'm
very sorry for your loss and i write my
own secret
i'm a priest who doesn't believe i feel
like i'm not able to give a lot of
insight as someone who isn't really
religious but i think
even as a
priest who doesn't believe
um you can be
a really important figure for people who
do believe
because
the role is so
selfless and outwards facing
yeah extends to the
non-non-religious community as well
i was disappointed when i found out my
dad didn't have cancer
i mean i think that is
like very crazy but also people have
such a variety of relationships and i
think it is important for people to have
like
space to express a multiplicity of
feelings around grief or proximity to
grief
um i don't feel like super in a position
to
i guess interpret that emotional
reaction
given lack of context and lack of
connection i think that it's important
to like have space to process like get
like a variety of emotions around grief
rather than singular narratives those
are my general thoughts
my turn
i'm gonna read some secrets or maybe
just one let's see
okay this one says i'm finally proud of
myself and know my worth for the first
time in years i'm happy
okay that's a really good one
it starts off with i'm finally proud
which makes me think that it's been
something that that they've struggled
with for a while
so
i'm sorry for that but i'm glad that you
finally are where you are uh seems like
you're living a beautiful life so and
thanks for sharing this next up
i think i made the wrong decision on
what i want to do with my life
[Music]
it's never too late
to try something new
that's what i have to say that's the
best advice i gave myself before i
started this before i got into
filmmaking so i'm passing it along to
you
i hope you're watching
imposter syndrome is an inescapable part
of my day-to-day life
hmm
all right guys that's it for today i
just wanted to read some before i stop
filming because it's getting pretty dark
but not all the secrets that were read
today were left by people you saw in the
video some of them were sent in to me or
some of them were shared with me on this
other project i do on my instagram where
people send in secrets thank you for
watching thank you for everything i love
you all so much and i'll see you next
week
[Music]
you